[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
68 lipdo le sommaire de ce vendredi 27
septembre minute de silence et discours
en hommage à jacques chirac au conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les pensées
pour l'ex président de la république
décédé ce jeudi étaient nombreuses
les réactions à suivre 111 féminicide
depuis le début de l'année 2019 dont
quatre dans les yvelines
nous tout organise une grande marge de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes le 23 novembre
l'antenne d evelyne prévoit deux
réunions d'information qu'une
représentante du collectif sera avec
nous en plateau des conseils municipaux
de rentrer et parfois tendu le tout
premier forum de la création
d'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines et un forum de l'apprentissage
à l'université versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
nous ferons lot le tour de l'actualité
de la semaine dans le département
[Musique]
plus de 40 années de vie politique avait
fait de jacques chirac un visage
familier et que nous partagions ou non
ses idées ses combats nous
reconnaissions tous en cet homme qui
nous ressemble et nous rassemble est le
deuxième président de la république
français s'était éteint jeudi 26
septembre
de par son titre jacques chirac a marqué
l'histoire des français mais également
les carrières de nombreux élus des
yvelines
le conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui s'est
tenue jeudi soir a voulu lui rendre
hommage
reportage de mélanie poquet une minute
de silence et un discours pour le
conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce jeudi 26
septembre
des mots prononcés par le président qui
a côtoyé l'ancien chef de l'état jean
michel fourgous a travaillé deux ans
avec lui à la sortie de sciences po
c'est un homme
généreux il a nommé général tout le
monde pas uniquement avec la droite ou
la gauche il et il a quelque chose et il
a il avait un je dirais une force de
travail hors norme une mémoire assez
impressionnante qui m'a toujours
impressionné il avait le sens de
l'humour il avait il était bienveillant
avec la il aimait la france engagé en
politique pendant plus de 40 ans jacques
chirac a inspiré de nombreux politiques
saint quentinois notamment chez les plus
jeunes
un grand homme d'état qui me quitte
aujourd'hui avec qui j'ai grandi parce
que j'ai 37 ans et mon premier vote je
me souviens c'est en 2000 pour le
référendum sur le quinquennat et ensuite
voilà j'ai voté pour lui en 2002 c'est
aussi toute ma construction politique
puisque j'avais adhéré à l'ump à
l'époque quand c'était la grande famille
de la droite et du centre
en tant que jeune élu c'est vrai que c
est forcément un personnage qui m'a
marqué qui m'a marqué par l'humanité qui
ne mettait dans tout ce qu'il faisait et
que tout le monde a ressenti comme l
amour est bien pour tous ses concitoyens
pour son pays et puis aussi son combat
contre les extrêmes
un hommage populaire à l'ancien chef
d'état est organisé dimanche 29
septembre à paris un moment de
recueillement a été demandée par
matignon lundi 30 septembre à 15h dans
les mairies en 2006 jacques chirac
recevait angela merkel à la préfecture
des yvelines dans le cadre d'une
rencontre franco allemande
aucun chef d'état en exercice n'était
venu dans cette préfecture depuis le
général de gaulle retour sur cet
événement dans notre rubrique ça s'est
passé
[Musique]
il est un peu moins de 22 heures avec un
petit quart d'heure de retard sur le
programme la rencontre franco-allemande
s'achève angela merkel raccompagné par
le chef de l'état quitte la préfecture
des yvelines
la journée marathon sa chef vous savez
que depuis le général de gaulle
c'est à dire depuis le 16 juin 65 aucun
chef d'état en exercice était venu dans
cette préfecture et donc plus de 40 ans
après être venu pour une réunion de
cette importance à l'occasion de
l'inauguration de cette superbe
exposition des musées de dhr est au
château de versailles est bien pour
cette maison c'était effectivement un
très grand honneur
cette rencontre officielle se prépare
dans les moindres détails depuis une
quinzaine de jours tout a été réglé par
les services du protocole allemand et
français
la sécurité bien sûr mais aussi le choix
des salons en passant par les fleurs le
menu et l'emplacement des caméras dans
la cour après un entretien entre
délégations à huis clos en gueule à
merkel et jacques chirac se présente
devant la presse il est aux alentours de
19h20 il sera bien sûr question de la
baisse de la tva pour la restauration
repoussée à une date ultérieure mais
aussi de l'apprentissage des langues dès
le plus jeune âge
il ya une équipe surtout l'opportunité
de commencer l'apprentissage des langues
dès le plus jeune âge de lire dès
l'école primaire et je crois que le plus
tôt on commence avant 10h devant le veut
cela serait lé même si pour l'instant on
le fait un peu trop tard en allemagne il
est indispensable de faire en sorte que
tous les européens
le plug in est possible soit dans
l'obligation dès le plus jeune âge à
l'école d'apprendre de nantes
et c'est le meilleur moyen de faciliter
la diffusion à la fois de l'allemand et
le français
[Musique]
jacques chirac qui à son arrivée au
pouvoir en 1995 constitue avec alain
juppé le gouvernement le plus féminisé
de l'histoire elles sont douze donc
quatre ministres mais ce gouvernement ne
tiendra pas plus de six mois et la
nouvelle équipe n'en comporte que quatre
il n'empêche qu'ils impulsent cette
volonté de féminisation de l'exécutif
avec même la nomination de michèle
alliot marie comme ministre de la
défense en 2011
elle est la première femme à occuper
cette fonction plusieurs lois concernant
les droits des femmes sont passées
durant son septennat et son quinquennat
elle s'affiche sur votre écran et même
concernant les violences conjugales la
loi de 2004 sur le divorce introduit la
procédure d'éviction du conjoint violent
en 2006 c'est une loi sur la prévention
et la répression des violences au sein
de couples qui est votée la notion de
respect apparaît également dans le
contrat de mariage gay elle démarre vous
êtes notre invité du jour bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous représentez l'antenne
yvelinoise nous tout le collectif
féministe vous en souvenez vous de ces
lois du début des années 2000 alors je
m'en souvenais pas précisément non
mais ce qu'on peut voir c'est que ça ne
suffit pas parce qu'actuellement on a
des chiffres énormes encore de violence
envers les femmes et les enfants
donc il faut aller plus loin et c'est
pour ça que l'on se mobilise aujourd'hui
avec le collectif nous tout ortement ou
appareils de politique nous tous tongres
offert notre page sur la mort de jacques
chirac pour retrouver d'autres réactions
dans notre jt du jeudi 26 septembre en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile on l'a appris ce
matin laissant 10e et 111e féminicide de
l'année jeudi 26 septembre à l'oeil les
roses dans le val de marne
une femme de 86 ans a été tué par balle
par son mari de 80 ans nous aurons ainsi
qu à muret dans la haute garonne
une femme de 69 ans aurait été tuée par
son compagnon de 58 ans c'est ce dernier
qui a prévenu les secours
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
déclaré comme grande cause nationale du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron que mon
style pour lutter conte pour lutter et
éradiquer ces féministes
il faudrait déjà que les femmes soient
davantage écoutés que leurs plaintes
soient prises en compte et qui est les
décisions de justice qu'ils aillent
davantage en faveur de leur protection
ce qu'on voit qu'il ya dans les
féminicides qui évolue encore récemment
des femmes qui avaient porté plainte à
de multiples reprises
et malheureusement elles n'ont pas été
protégé correctement alors parmi ces 111
féminicide quatre se sont déroulées dans
les yvelines contre un en 2018
quelles solutions existent un des deux
départements alors dans notre
département il faut en cas de problèmes
de violence il faut prendre contact avec
des associations qui sont spécialisés
comme le plein le planning familial le
cidff
il ya le numéro national du 39 19 aussi
qui peut être contacter en cas de
problème pour être conseiller et
orienter correctement des associations
qui s'affiche à votre écran
le 3 septembre dernier a été lancé le
grenelle des violences conjugales deux
premières annonces ont été faites par le
premier ministre 5 millions d'euros pour
la création de 1000 nouvelles places
d'hébergement d'urgence
la possibilité de porter plainte à
l'hôpital la création de procureurs
référents spécialisés et la mise en
place effective du bracelet électronique
anti rapprochement à partir de 2020 des
réunions locales ont lieu dans toute la
france avec une première réunion dans
les yvelines le 13 septembre dernier
d'autres sont à venir qu'attendez-vous
de ce grenelle où on attend qu'ils aient
des moyens qu'ils soient assez
conséquent pour que ce soit efficace
je me demande mon en terme de budget
c'est un milliard d'euros ce qu'on voit
qu'en espagne c'est ce qui a été mis sur
la table et que c'est efficace le nombre
de féminicide a été considérablement
réduits donc il faut pas que ce soit
seulement des opérations communication
qu'ils soient effectués mais qui est des
vrais moyens pour pouvoir protéger les
femmes
on a déjà cette cellule d'écouté lcl est
efficace elle est efficace mais derrière
il faut qu'ils aient des solutions des
centres des places en centre
d'hébergement qu'ils soient créés et que
tous les maillons de la chaîne en fait
soit formé au niveau de la police au
niveau de la justice et il faut pas
qu'ils aient seulement le
volet répressif après coup qu'il soit
mis en oeuvre il ya aussi toute une
partie éducation qui doit être fait en
amont pour éviter que ces violences
continuent à perdurer
donc on propose aussi de sensibiliser
les enfants dans les écoles au niveau
collège par exemple au notion de
consentement et de violences sexistes et
sexuelles parce que c'est pas le cas
encore dans les écoles c'est pas
obligatoire donc et c'est un peu du
saupoudrage en fait donc non proposerait
par exemple qu'il ya un brevet qui soit
passé par les enfants un peu comme le
système des brevets de sécurité routière
comme ça ça permettrait de valider un
peu c'est que ces notions là sont
acquises
alors on revient à la jussie cette
information de la semaine dernière la
région ile de france qui avait fait de
la lutte contre les violences wentzo
faites aux femmes sa grande cause
régionale en 2017 a voté pour demander
au gouvernement la reconnaissance du
féminisme dans le code pénal
qu'est ce que cette reconnaissance
changerait au moins ça permet quand on
met un mot officiellement sur ce type de
violences a permis que ce soit vraiment
reconnu
donc ça permet de beaucoup faire avancer
les choses
là rien que le fait d'en parler de
décompter ce nombre de féministes dans
les médias on voit que le sujet prend de
l'ampleur et que peut-être on aura des
moyens d'action plus important donc le
fait que ce soit reconnue par la loi je
pense que ça que ça peut beaucoup aider
les mots comptent et parmi ces moyens
d'action le collectif nous tout qui est
né l'année dernière pour cette grande
marche organisée contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes moment il ya une
déclinaison locale donc nous tout
soixante dix huit que vous représentez
cette marche revient en 2019 le 23
novembre à 14 heures à paris et pour la
préparer vous organisez des réunions à
pois ce soir et attrapes dans quinze
jours le 10 octobre mais c'est ça donc
ce sont des réunions d'information et de
mobilisation
des réunions d'information parce qu'on
fait des formations sur les mécanismes
des violences et sur la manière de
réagir si jamais soi-même ou parmi notre
entourage on est amené à rencontrer des
victimes de violence que malheureusement
on voit que c'est assez fréquent et que
ça peut toucher tous les milieux donc
voilà donc il ya cette partie formation
et sensibilisation et ensuite dans une
deuxième partie de la réunion
on fait plus de la mobilisation pour la
marche l'objectif c'est d'être 100
milles dans la rue le 23 novembre pour
faire pression sur le gouvernement pour
que les moyens nécessaires soient
alloués et donc on va mener des actions
locales jusqu'au 23 novembre pour
essayer de sensibiliser un maximum de
gens à cette cause pour retrouver toutes
les informations sur vos événements il
ya votre page facebook qui va s'afficher
vous espérez qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'événements a peut-être yvelinoise dans
cette marie on espère on en parle
beaucoup autour de nous et on espère les
voir nombreux aussi à nos réunions et en
effet sur les réseaux sociaux on est
très active et actif et vous pouvez sur
toutes nos actualités sur facebook et
instagram
merci gueuler marre d'être venu sur
notre plateau on rappelle vos deux
réunions poissy ce soir à 20h trappe le
10 octobre également à 20 heures et bien
sûr la marche du 20 novembre à paris
dans le reste de l'actualité elle est
spécialisée dans les tests pour la
qualification des produits depuis l'an
passé l'entreprise imitait cas de
nouveaux locaux à montigny le bretonneux
des espaces plus grands pour développer
son activité
patrick jane de dixmude et grégory canal
et on peut suivre quelques essais 6000
m² de laboratoires et mitec a vu grand
pour mener au mieux ces tests dans la
certification et la mise au point des
produits dans les domaines grand public
aéronautique et médicales les nouveaux
locaux à montigny le bretonneux met les
150 salariés dans les meilleures
dispositions pour mener des essais de
résistance aux chocs secoue ses
vibrations
ce sont des des locaux dans lequel au
même endroit à un client peut faire
l'ensemble des essais 1 que je ai dit
compatibilité électromagnétique et c'est
donc c'est extrêmement important
c'est un lieu unique au lieu qu'elle le
client peut réaliser l'ensemble de ses
besoins décès des essais menés notamment
sur la capacité des matériaux à résister
au feu dans les avions
pourquoi en général on génère un
ensemble et air carburant
la partie supérieure du matériel est un
matériel qui va être soit un plancher
soit un plafond en intérieur en f
la résistance des matériaux qui sont mis
en oeuvre elles doivent assurer
effectivement la capacité d'une part de
pau extinction une capacité de
résistance est évidemment une capacité
dans le pire des cas d'évacuation dans
ses laboratoires emitech peut également
en recréer les vibrations d'un trajet
quotidien qu'ils soient routiers
ferroviaires ou aériens si vous voyez
comment ce départ de la règle cette
france là donc on va avoir c'est
effectivement en subissant ces
vibrations
on va parler des dégradations des noms
fond de réalité qui pourrait être
critique pour le fonctionnement de
l'appareil à partir des essais menés
comme sur ces câblage de véhicules à qui
l'on a fait subir des perturbations un
rapport est transmis aux clients qui
décidera avec les autorités et de la
mise en équipement des appareils
en fait c'est et c'est donc en pré
qualification et qualification pour pour
une fois qu'il est monté sur le véhicule
qui est que le client n'ait pas d'impact
sur l'utilisation du véhicule emitech
travaille avec des grands groupes comme
safran valeo et thales l'entreprise
enregistre chaque année une croissance
de 10%
un forum de l'apprentissage pour vous
pousse t son projet professionnel se
dérouler jeudi dans les locaux de la
maison de l'étudiant de l'université
versailles saint quentin à guyancourt
destiné à tous les jeunes de 15 à 29 ans
qui n'ont pas de solution d'alternance
en cette fin du mois de septembre sur
place 17 cfa centre de formation pour
apprentis étaient représentés pour
proposer les dernières offres
d'apprentissage disponibles sur le
territoire
propos recueillis par mathilde minuit
les centres de formation d'apprentis ils
viennent avec leurs offres à pourvoir
dans des entreprises parce qu'elles sont
mandatés par le par les entreprises pour
trouver un candidat donc les cfa sont là
pour recruter pour des entreprises et
pour que les jeunes intègrent leur
formation et soient formés en alternance
donc en apprentissage avec des heures de
formation au cfa et des heures de
travail en entreprise le quartier du
vally boas plaisir a connu des nuits
agitées du 19 au 21 septembre des
violences ont éclaté
poupet poubelles ensemble
et affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre l'origine est à ce jour
inexpliqué la mère de plaisir dresse un
état des lieux au micro de nicolas
landry la situation semble être revenue
à la normale nous avons fait le
nécessaire pour essayer de comprendre
avec toutes les institutions que ce soit
police nationale et puis la commission
municipale mais également tous les
partenaires que nous avons sur le
quartier visiblement c'est une secousse
qui s'est produite a été assez violente
faut le reconnaître
moi je suis très honnête qui nous
surprend parce qu'avec tout le travail
qui est fait sur le quartier dans le
cadre de la réhabilitation mais
également dans le cadre du rapprochement
avec les femmes avec des associations
c'est quelque chose qui nous surprend et
on se dit que finalement ça ne vient pas
de l'intérieur du vally beau ça doit
venir de l'extérieur certainement
comment échanger avec moi plusieurs
maires comme quoi également sur leur
quartier il y avait des espèces de
mouvements de cet ordre là l'origine je
n'en sais strictement rien en tout cas
je sais que je ne lâche pas prise
je continue d'aller au valais bout nous
continuons d'avoir des actions sur le
valier bout parce que ce que je veux
c'est que le vélib ou s'améliore et il
est en train de le faire alors sage est
peut-être certaines personnes
[Musique]
des bouleversements dans les majorités
des municipalités à de villepreux et
plaisir à villepreux pour commencer le
maire stéphane mirambeau s'est retrouvée
seule suite à des plaintes pour
harcèlement sexuel
il s'est retiré durant l'été avant de
revenir en cette rentrée
ce retour entraîné l'explosion de la
majorité le maire a alors annoncé ne pas
se représenter pour les élections de
2020 ce mardi 24 septembre se tenait le
conseil municipal de groupes issus de la
majorité des missionnaires se sont
formés et un conseiller municipal a été
le premier adjoint conditions pour que
la commune est vite la mise sous tutelle
on écoute la réaction de stéphane
mirambeau faut bien avoir en tête que si
je démissionnais aujourd'hui conseil
municipal et dise où on revote et dans
quatre mois on revote je pense pas que
ce soit le mieux pour la ville je vais
dick idée des affaires courantes il ya
des gros projets qui sont encore là il
faut qu'on pense à a eu des tensions
également un plaisir ou dès le début de
conseil municipal trois membres de la
majorité demandent qu'à prendre la
parole pour une annonce et démissionnent
et rejoignent le groupe ensemble avant
son pur plaisir
affiliée à la république en marche une
décision qui amorcent les élections
municipales dès 2020 joséphine coleman
berger au micro de nicolas gendry
surprise pas trop vraiment plus tôt je
dirais une confirmation est bien de dan
opportunisme qui me semble évident parce
que quand on partage cinq ans et demi
des projets communs
quand on travaille ensemble pendant cinq
ans et demi je peux que m'interroger je
dirais sur les vrais fondamentaux d'une
démission comme celle ci à quelques mois
des élections et vous pouvez retrouver
les reportages complets sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
mardi 24 septembre était organisée la
journée je crée ma boîte
une première à saint quentin en yvelines
un forum sur la création d'entreprise
toute la journée plusieurs partenaires
de ce qui fut bon conseiller et apporter
des réponses à des entrepreneurs
un reportage de nicolas d'andry et
rodolphe blondel accompagnement
financement expertise réseau et
immobilier d'entreprise les acteurs de
la création d'entreprise au forum je
crée ma boîte
un événement organisé par saint quentin
en yvelines et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines objectif
conseiller et orienter les entrepreneurs
dans leurs démarches de création
la plupart du temps les porteurs de
projets viennent en disant j'ai une idée
je veux savoir la meilleure forme
juridique kim qui me convient et les
aides que je peux avoir
donc mon rôle c'est dans un premier
temps c'est à dire c'est bien de vous
poser ces questions-là
mais ce n'est pas que ça avant il faut
poser votre projet par écrit pour savoir
si votre projet est bien parmi les
visiteurs cédric leroy son projet créer
une société de conseil dans le domaine
du sport avec pour cible le marché
indien
j'étais un petit peu perdues pour être
tout à fait franc avec vous il ya
énormément de statut de société qui
existe j'ai pris des renseignements un
petit peu sur internet mais je me suis
vite rendu compte qu'il y avait une
limite à tout ça et que c'était
important de pouvoir échanger avec des
personnes physiques et a pris justement
qui avait un service international au
niveau de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie ce que je ne savais pas du
tout donc j'ai fait une prise de
rendez-vous il m'accompagneront ensuite
sur justement le choix de
mon statut d'entreprise de son côté
sybille capelle veut développer une
plateforme de recrutement
une démarche après plusieurs années
passées en entreprise demandeurs
d'emploi elles se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat qui est un réseau qui
est très très bien ficelé et qui aide
grandement les créateurs d'entreprise
d'edel en brillant l'idée donc c'est
plutôt sympa statut juridique protection
sociale étude de marché des thèmes
abordés dans ses ateliers à l'intérieur
du ski cube c'est des ateliers de 45
minutes généralement il ya une
demi-heure en fait d'intervention du
formateur de l'expert de la thématique
et derrière il ya toujours 15 minutes
d'échangés avec les participants au
premier trimestre 2010 9 plus de 5200
entreprises ont été créées dans les
yvelines
durant ce forum othman nzru vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge du développement économique a
répondu aux questions de nicolas landry
extrait du 7-8 journal de mercredi 25
septembre on est sur un territoire
sa crainte en yvelines qui est
particulièrement dynamique et un des
poumons économiques de l'île de france
il est important naturellement qu'on
accompagne tous les créateurs pour créer
les emplois de demain
c'est d'abord souvent des emplois pour
ceux qui créent leur entreprise qui
décide entre guillemets de se mettre à
leur compte et puis ça permet de créer
aussi de nouveaux emplois vous donne un
seul chiffre parmi les entreprises que
nous accompagnons moins que nous
accompagnons pardon ici à saint quentin
en yvelines
80% d'entre elles créent au bout de deux
ans plus de deux emplois et 25 mille
participants sont attendus au pied de la
tour eiffel samedi pour cette 42e
édition du paris versailles
le premier départ est à 10 heures une
course emblématique dont le parcours est
inchangé depuis 1975
le président de l'association
organisatrice au micro de maquereaux
margot du roi et rodolphe secondaire de
plats à paris pour bien s'échauffer du
départ jusqu'à le bas de la côte de
moudon et puis la fameuse côte de moudon
qui du fait deux kilomètres
j'ai suivi de plusieurs petites bosses
et une grande descente et ensuite encore
une grande côte à viroflay
et puis viroflay c'est le treizième
philo mais non via trois derniers
kilomètres qui sont légèrement difficile
aussi parce que c'est un plat montant
surtout ici sur versailles
sur la parité très large et donc on n'a
pas l'impression des distances et puis
surtout dès qu'il ya un peu de vent
toujours de face il s'agit de la plus
grande brocante de france 8 son stand
trente mille visiteurs attendus du monde
entier
la foire de château s'ouvre ce vendredi
27 septembre pour un peu plus d'une
semaine jusqu'au 6 octobre
après le cyclisme l'année dernière le
thème de cette 99e édition et les années
1980 une exposition d'affichés sera
présente
on écoute jean nowicki au micro
d'aurélie rose chaque marchand quand il
ya un thème et bien ils essayent d'avoir
quelque chose de ce thème vous allez
retrouver cette année dans les stands à
certains même dans beaucoup de fans des
choses des années 80 un collectionneur
il trouve son bonheur
un amateur d'art il trouve son bonheur
un amateur de 2,2 vintage comme on
appelle qui trouve son bonheur
en fait on chatou c'est un village
[Musique]
le haut débit pour tous et partout est
prévue d'ici fin 2020 de nombreux
chantiers sont en cours dans la région
pour le déploiement de la fibre
nos confrères devient grand paris un nom
souvient dans les yvelines
le déploiement de la fibre se poursuit
en ile-de-france le haut débit pour tous
et partout est prévue d'ici fin 2020 et
le très haut débit pour 2022
aujourd'hui plus de 4,6 millions de
logements sont éligibles à la fibre en
ile de france et c'est l'opérateur
orange qui a déployé 70 % du réseau 300
chantiers de l'opérateur historique sont
actuellement en cours dans la région
dont 51
rien que dans les yvelines la fibre dans
les yvelines c'est très simple nous
devons fibres et 102 communes elles
seront toutes terminées fin 2020 c'est
notre engagement et nous en avons déjà
terminé 52e dans ce qui nous laisse très
confiant pour atteindre cet objectif
peut-être même le devancer cette semaine
l'opérateur fêter son millionième abonné
fibre en ile-de-france pour l'heureux
élu
l'accès au très haut débit était devenue
indispensable
on est quatre personnes à utiliser
internet à la maison de à titre
professionnel et deux ados titre soit
gamer soit des démontages en matière de
vidéo et de l'animation dont qui demande
qu il est bon d'avoir un débit qui soit
stable et qui demande à voir du débit
aussi de la vitesse tout simplement ce
qui t'est pas automatiquement le cas
avant et c'est clair que depuis juillet
ça a un peu changé
on peut l'utiliser j'allais dire à 4
maintenant en même temps l'arrivée du
très haut débit pour tous voit également
apparaître de nouveaux usages qui sont
appelées à se développer
la domotique l utilisation de plus
d'objets connectés
de plus en plus d'objets connectés
rentrer dans les maisons aujourd'hui que
ce soit autour des frigos connecter des
robots de cuisine connecter des ampoules
connectés et bien pour faire fonctionner
tous ces objets connectés en même temps
il faut du débit la france rami 15 ans
pour déployer intégralement la fibre
contre 40 ans pour installer le
téléphone fixe
un record qui plaît
l'hexagone au premier rang des pays
fibré c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivi on se quitte
sur des images de l'installation de la
deuxième édition de trois rivières
sauvages qui débutera le 27 octobre
le reportage est à découvrir dès la
semaine prochaine dans notre 7,8 journal
bon week-end sur télé 78
[Musique]
oui
ouais ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
q
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]